Different people different worlds drawn to
each other like magnets you want to get nuts
let's get nuts I love you monkey I love you more
I love too first my mind will always be alive
I went back in time to save my mom
and I completely destroyed history
you've changed the future you changed the past
my mom she's the best and
kindest person in the world
you have to tell her that moms like to hear these
kind of things
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
they just dropped a bunch of new Flash trailers so
we'll break it all down there's a whole bunch of
new footage in Easter eggs if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos one of the biggest things it's not
in these trailers but it's separately director
Andy muschietti just drew and posted a picture of
what looks like the reverse flash it definitely
doesn't look like one of Ezra Miller's versions
of the flash two different versions in the movie
there are a couple different flashes in this movie
but the reverse flash isn't supposed to be a big
character during this first Flash Film as you see
here on his Instagram the costume is yellow with
red highlights like negative speed force and the
smile looks like a very eobardathon evil kind of
smile the overall costume itself seems a little
bit like his costume like Barry's brand new Flash
costume that's given to him in the flash ring by
Batman but here's the thing The Flash symbol on
it is pointing the same way as the normal Flash
symbol reverse flash makes his symbol point the
opposite direction of the flashes so what might
be going on here is having a little bit of fun
making a Sly reference at the dark Flash twist
in this movie that we already know about where
the younger Berry kind of becomes an evil flesh
fighting against the normal flash using a crazy
looking kryptonian-based flash suit eventually for
most of the movie he wears a homemade version of
The Flash suit that they sort of cobbled together
like they dumpster dive together using one of
Batman's old armor suits that's why it looks
so weird like there's even more footage that
they posted on their Twitter account but during
most of the movie he's wearing a yellow jacket
reverse Flash's color is yellow so I think what
they're doing in this movie is that instead of
just directly going to reverse flash they're
holding off on that character for a while he
might still be part of Flash's backstory in the
death of his mother because he's so important to
the flash point of it all like the whole reason
why Barry goes back in the future in the first
place to try and save his mother but it seems
like what they're doing is they're just using
some Easter eggs for reverse flash and combining
that with this dark flash twist where really it's
the younger bear who's like 10 years younger
than the present day Barry who doesn't fully
learn the lesson like no you're not supposed to
change time even though you have the ability to
try and change time just because it leads to even
worse things like it will only make things worse
there's also a brand new scene it's kind
of janky that footage isn't super great
quality but there's a funny scene of
him trying to give the younger Barry
The Flash ring and teach him about the flash suit
gives us to put it on before it hits
the floor back in time I completely
built the universe wants to know but
he's Batman he's done let's get nuts
Barry what are you doing our kids are gonna want
to see this during that they also have that new
funny scene of him telling his younger self that
Batman really is Bruce Wayne and him not believing
it like wait a minute you're telling me that Bruce
Wayne is really Batman that's ridiculous it also
seems like he's stuffing his face with something
too like he's got food all over his mouth that's
probably a reference to Barry Allen just eating he
calls himself a snack hole in the Justice League
movie caused me to burn a tremendous amount of
calories so I'm just a black hole of snacks I am
a snack hole if he didn't catch the more recent
episodes of The Flash TV show because it's the
last couple of episodes of The Flash TV show like
it's ending in a couple episodes they actually had
John Wesley's ship back on it had a big reference
to the original flash 1990s TV series during the
scene you see them take Barry to a pizza shop
where he eats a ton of pizzas which is basically
a big plot point during that original 1990s Flash
series where he just eats a crazy number of pizzas
you want this one you know
help yourself great thanks
did you uh would you like another one just because
as the flash they tried to explain that his body
Burns crazy calories when he's running fast
the way they get around that in more modern
incarnations especially in the comics too is
they're always references to him having to eat a
lot burning a lot of calories but really what they
do is they just say that the speed force Works
in a way that allows them to break the laws of
physics and it becomes kind of a hand wavy thing
where it solves a lot of those logic issues but
it does sound like they share some funny moments
during the movie when he tries to explain to his
younger self how he becomes the flash like this
is how these Powers work like obviously he has
to explain it in some way but it probably did in
a pretty quick funny way just hold on for a second
I'm gonna shock you with some lightning it's going
to be the most painful thing that you'll ever
experience but you will have super powers after
we're done wait a minute what and then boom he
gets shocked with lightning during the other
clip where he says different people different
worlds drawn to each other that's just a reference
to the overlapping timelines where Batman 1989
Michael Keaton's timeline crosses over with the
regular flashes Justice League timeline and Kara's
Supergirl timeline crosses over the way they're
explained cleaning time travel in the different
timelines crossing over the whole flash point
of it all is a little bit like the Loki series
with timelines and it seems like what winds up
happening on this Earth is that you have a bunch
of time lapse because the speed force just sort
of crosses them over so it all feels like they
came from the same timeline even though that's
not the case there were references to the flash
during the original Batman 1989 like there's the
Mercury helmet but I don't know what their plans
were originally when Tim Burton was making those
movies maybe they thought that someday they could
do some other DC characters during those but at
that point the only other really successful
movie franchise that Warner Brothers had done
from the DC Comics was the original Christopher
Reeve Superman there were some cool Easter eggs
for a classic version of Justice League but this
was just a promo that was done like I don't know
if they ever actually planned on pulling this
off but like you have all these original OG
characters who were the biggest versions at this
time in history we've been talking about them
eventually doing like a big crisis on infinite
Earths in the movies it would be cool if when
they did that they found a way to pay this kind
of scene off where you do have a classic version
the Justice League the whole idea with the
continuity behind his Batman in this movie
though is that the Batman 1989 and the Batman
Returns movie are the only things that are
Canon to his timeline they're basically treating
Val Kilmer's Batman Forever and George Clooney's
Batman and Robin as completely separate universes
each individually there's supposed to be some sort
of funny post-credits scene at the end of the
movie where Barry accidentally runs into another
timeline and it winds up being George Clooney
Batman's Universe like wait a minute what are
you doing here oh I did it again oh crap the same
way that when he goes looking for Batman earlier
in the movie he finds Michael Keaton's Batman like
wait a minute you're not the Batman I expected to
find it also seems like there's an Easter egg for
the Christian Bale Batman when he's run through
the speed force here in this concept art you can
actually see him over on the right here the whole
idea with the movies they're using the flashpoint
twist to sort of soft reboot into James Gunn's
rebooted DC movies like they're calling it the
DCU with the new Superman Legacy movie the new
version of Batman and Batman Brave and the Bold
basically like a whole new universe with some
actors being being the same but for the most part
a lot of new actors playing all the Justice League
characters but I think in addition to that they're
also trying to use this movie in the Multiverse
aspect of it all to canonize everything to
like the larger DC Multiverse so that when
they eventually do a big Multiverse movie like
Crisis on infinite Earth they can bring everyone
back and it'll make sense Henry Cavill talked
a lot about coming back I just did a Superman
Legacy video where he basically referenced that
he talked to James Gunn about possibly coming
back in the future and I think that was meant to
be a Multiverse kind of twist and speaking of the
new version of Superman the new version of Batman
that they're eventually introducing in these new
James Gunn movies what we know so far is that we
won't actually see those characters like the new
versions of the characters for a good long while
like they're not going to show up in this movie
or anything like that like Henry Cavill Superman
is supposed to have a cameo still in this movie
the new Superman Legacy movie is what James Gunn
views is like the actual traditional beginning
of his DCU and he said during that movie we're
actually going to see it populated with a lot
of the other big DC characters already they'll
already exist in the universe I don't know if
that means that he's also going to include the
new version of Batman during that in some way
or maybe some small reference to him but the
new Batman brave in the Bold movie I believe
is coming out in 2026 the year after so it's not
like Superman Legacy is going to come along in a
couple years and during that movie superban is the
only big character that's in that movie the other
brand new footage they released is with Kirsty
Clemens Iris West and we haven't seen footage of
her in the trailers before but this is the clip
of her coming to see him can we talk foreign
I'm not gonna lie it's a lot
tidier in here than I expected
can I offer you a drink sure zoom in enhance
you may have also spotted a Pennywise Easter
egg in the background here in Barry's apartment
that's because Andy muschietti also directed The
it movies he's also working on the it prequel
welcome to Dairy the other Easter egg that he
included was a Guillermo del Toro Pacific Rim
Easter egg because on one of his first movies
Guillermo del Toro became an executive producer
and helped him make it so in addition to all
the regular DC Easter eggs for other DC movies
there's a lot of Easter eggs for Andy mushy it
is just real life in general he's also wearing
the same outfit when he talks to the Ben Affleck
Batman about the whole flash point of it all
and the other interesting thing too is that
when he's telling Batman about the whole concept
of Flashpoint like I think I can travel back in
time and change history I think I could bring my
mother back I think I could bring your parents
back too when they're having that scene Batman
is standing with a marquee behind him a theater
Marquee so it's another reference to Crime Alley
the death of his parents Thomas and Martha Wayne
Andy muschietti did say that there would be a
flash sequel like the flash too just depending
on what the box office is like and it seems like
people think the movie is going to do pretty well
but James Gunn didn't say anything about what's
going to happen to Ezra Miller like will they
recast honestly I'd be totally fine if they just
recast the character if they want to keep using
this version of The Flash let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do with the
future of the flash character in this brand new
James Gunn rebooted DC Universe there are a couple
big giveaways that are still going on in my Marvel
videos right now so I'll name winners in the next
couple of days there was just a huge announcement
about the casting and the actors that are going
to be in Superman Legacy click here to learn about
that and click here for my brand new Venom 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!